why don't you look properly I've got
multiple sclerosis are you weird I've
got special power I think is on the
spectrum traits of autism hi can i order
number four seven please
my son is quite picky he needs a meal in
order to be a prime number and the prime
number of prawn balls
there is no question be unique young man
listen Ellis the dragon was not often we
have a mind like yours ring up off the
radar leave mine in a two-seater for
seven years
you have successfully under place on the
United Kingdom and like any good study I
really like to carry on teacher Nathan
me that's why were you yes you're just
talking Nathan the cliff is young raised
in this country we will be training
before other national teams please to me
this beauty is truth and truth is beauty
and then surely mathematics is the most
beautiful thing ever
followed by a 1 10 to the 0 good work
everyone
the other amazing thing is in the future
charming little bastard
this is the most prestigious place to
study mathematics on the planet nothing
will ever find
Kreacher come on
round of my brain works differently
somebody loves you
is worth something excited
typical Sean and Lanisha al-sabah
Gus clutch liquidity haven't in local
fauna especially visas gladly I know my
net every pick our own house about
finding funds that saved us